foreign
okay
let's see so we are having a discussion
here about types for the compiler and
the curation of the types that were from
language built-in functions take and
return
that a fair characterization of what
we're doing here yes yes so we want you
want to be systematic about this and
actually Jose has some interesting stuff
to show as well so
um so this is like a kickoff meeting to
sort of survey right and the objective
here
is to be able to do this both for the
compiler to be able to do your your
kernel function wrapper for the compiler
right for compiled code being able to
call into built-in code using this
kernel function thing with a typewrapper
is that correct that's that's one of the
goals but as I point out here you in in
some ways you don't really need that's
an implementation and if you want to do
you remember you were talking about
verification I know I know I know I was
I was I was just I was just beginning my
little little sprite yeah right so
identifying code doesn't need an
implementation I'm aware I'm aware but
but so so I'm just I'm just trying to
make sure that we we have an end point
in mind here so the first end point is
yes the kernel function callback wrapper
correct right fine so so different
implementations there's a kernel you
know kernel function callback to the
evaluator okay
um and I've listed some there's some
pros and cons to this then there's a
link to internal functions right which
goes yes we're aware of this right and
then there's employees right fine and
then there's direct implementation I
don't like at all okay so go back to the
first one of those and let's just look
at the issues
okay
why is it incurs evaluator overhead well
yeah I mean why
because what aspect of the evaluator I
mean can't we short circuit some parts
of the evaluator once we know that um
this type of information maybe we can't
it's going through the evaluator so if
it's something that could be done more
quickly you know Etc that's that's an
issue well so my question is what is the
evaluator overhead because I mean for
example the evaluation of the arguments
to the function will already have been
done correct
that's correct right so the evaluation
required
right but but but the evaluator then
doesn't need to do that so for example
in this curation process knowing that
that would already have happened and the
compiler will be useful because it
allows one to Short Circuit I mean
basically basically the only thing one's
going to be doing is calling the down
code there's nothing else
and I would have thought having the
evaluator because some of the many of
these functions have down value from
implementations as well
I'm not sure there's much to be gained
by you know going straight to the down
code we that that could be experimented
with
okay but so my question is
I mean and we also know what the
overhead is because we might be you know
trying to shoot down
what we think is a giant Albatross and
actually it's a little tiny Sparrow
fine that's that's uh I'm making a note
right what one other kind of con of both
these first two and this is only
solvable by implementation of the
compiler is that that I mean if you're
writing compiled code the only types
that you can pass to and from you know
basically the kernel are types that are
serializable as expressions and of
course there's then the serialization
cost
correct I mean if you have a if you have
some weird kind of type that only lives
in the compiler which may maybe the goal
should be that no such types of physical
types serialized expressions in some way
or another but but if you have some
weird unserializable thing then uh you
know then you're out of luck I mean but
the only way that look the ultimate way
to do this
is to go directly you know for crunchy
algorithmic functions is to go directly
to the country to an internal crunchy
algorithmic you know endpoint
um and bypass all of the kind of fluff
code that deals with kind of expression
level stuff because that will be handled
somewhere different
but you know that's a very complicated
implementation effort that's a long-term
thing
so I mean yes that's neat we shouldn't
go there we shouldn't go that we we you
know what we should do is the kernel
function thing is the primary target and
you know it's worth talking to and it's
a complicated project management effort
um
you know people in different kernel
development groups who might have
structured their code so that this call
to an internal function is possible
am I making sense
it's it's it's it's possible yes no no
no no no no no no no I want a little bit
more understanding what I'm saying here
I don't what you're saying is talking to
internal groups might find that they
wrote A specialized function that could
be called directly from the compiler and
that is true yes right so I mean we
might find that like I assume Rob
there are many many problems to that
because what's going to happen is the
next version the internal group will
have Rewritten that function to work in
a different way well no but they're not
expecting it to be boiled
outside okay
everything has problems we need to find
a solution yeah yeah fine right right
right so so what what's being done what
we're talking about here is if it so
happens that a bunch of implementation
has been done so there is a fairly clean
essentially sea level or something API
layer
then we should find that out and maybe
for the optimization code that's been
done or the graph Theory code that's
been done I don't know but let's find
out because well but either way I think
that again we still don't really know
what the benefit is of doing that versus
just a straight kernel function through
the evaluator we don't I agree the
kernel function is definitely and also
the kernel functions like in terms of
implementation even right now it's
trivial like if you have the type
signature great it's a one-line thing to
Define it
that's exactly what we want and you know
the strategy that we should have and
we're not you know this is this is how
we deliver something now rather than a
decade from now is what we've talked
about many times which is everything
compiles in quotes it may just be a
bunch of Kernel function calls
and
that's you know
uh
right yeah so because I mean I think
yes
I think that that should be the target I
mean I don't I don't see why yeah okay
also I mean for the purpose of this
meeting I'm not sure the implementation
details I'm just trying to make sure
that we actually have an end point and
that we know what we're tagging so I
mean that's a project management thing
to go and ask people to Define what it
is we would need from the internal
functions and then find out if it's
there right and we're not even going to
talk about implementation of the
compiler because that's just that's
that's just a you know that's like
re-implement the whole system so let's
not even go there okay so the primary
thing we're looking at is the kernel
function approach
um
okay so now keep going
yeah it's fine wait wait a minute we're
talking about objectives so another
objective is for code assistance
presumably I mean this is something that
can be used that's that's what this is
supposed to mean
yes but in particular that means that
layers of the compiler I mean is there
an API is there an interface to the
compiler yeah we talked about this
target with types thing right
let's define our objectives here okay so
one objective is function compile can
compile almost anything but often
spraying kernel function stuff in it
right that's objective one do we agree
Tom do we agree about that objective
yeah yes yes yes I'm writing down
because it's right I'm well we have Uber
here who should be able to
what I like to make notes as well I
wasn't paying attention to this yes okay
you don't usually complain when people
make notes right no I don't I'm sorry I
just wasn't wasn't looking at yeah yeah
no that's that's that's all fine all
right okay so now
okay second point
here
yeah I think that the initial objective
should be
given
a piece of code
be able to annotate it with type hints
as far as it can does that make sense
well I I think if it can be typed then
it can be
given type hints yes but I'm not sure
what you mean do you mean just like I
mean run the type inferencer on it and
then just just just
type it at every level that's what I'm
doing I think that's what it means maybe
with better better ux I mean you Mouse
over and it tells you the type yes right
right exactly but now let's look at what
that means in terms of
uh because what that's going to tell one
is there are tight mismatches you know
in the case where it's linting code and
saying oops
you know there's a tight mismatch here
right so that will be an objective for
that part markup a code with markup code
with trees with type hints and be able
to notice that there are places where
you could not find but the type up will
be incomplete because if it meets an
inconsistency then it's going to stop at
that point okay but but that's exactly
where we have to sound the alarm Bells
yeah yeah fine right right
yeah well I understand that but it could
be the case that in a piece of code
hypothesis right that given a piece of
code
and you want to say where are the bugs
in my code
okay it is a possible hypothesis that
any place where the type inferencer
cannot successfully inference
is a potential bug correct that's that
that's correct
I mean that might not be right because
it could be that there that there are
enough things that are like your own
custom you know head-based
um uh you know expression based
um
uh structure that we can't do ordinary
type inference but yes but that's why we
have um things like type hint You See
yeah I understand but I'm I'm still
trying to think what are the rules in
the code assistant system okay so I'm
just trying to understand let's take the
example of the the famous example of
plot sine X comma X okay
and whether the type inferencer would
would um uh you know how it would deal
with that
I mean that yeah for example that there
needs to be a list around the section I
know but that's the whole point oh okay
it's an error so I mean the question is
what I want to know is where do we pick
up that error
okay is that a type error or is that a
completely different kind of error that
has nothing to do with the subsystem
well this is
there's no I mean obviously we'd have to
have a way to represent
this thing here as a type well yeah what
what is the type like
okay did you answer the question though
I mean I think well it depends on sort
of the order of things I mean I think it
could be a type error if nothing else
from the fact that has the wrong number
of arguments and and the later arguments
are clearly not options
um I mean in terms of encoding this in
the type system this is honestly one of
the harder examples because one there's
lots of options and options are right
now there isn't really good way of doing
options
for options we could we could have a
type for basically I think I think we I
think we can have types uh options with
the sequence thing Christopher sorry
okay fine fine the other thing is that
right now there isn't a great way of
encoding the types of like symbolic math
stuff I mean stuff that's basically
going to be unevaluated
um right I mean at least there's not
good ways of compiling it maybe they're
fine ways of representing the types so
that will be but but okay my point is we
need a plan that involves getting code
assistance that tells somebody this is
probably wrong
and we have been blocking on the code
assistant stuff on the grounds that oh
that needs a type system now maybe this
one doesn't maybe this is a different
path the difference you know code
assistance rules
can can you give an example can you give
kind of a type specimen and I meant that
sorry I I couldn't resist the joke never
mind a type specimen like those things
that go in you know
formaldehyde jaws and so on to prove
that a member of the species actually
exists
um the uh uh
um that's an instance of a type never
mind
um
right
uh but but you want to see an example of
like a you know piece of code and the
types for it yes and the types where
where in fact one could detect bugs by
doing type inference
right well here here it might be a nice
example so so if you could write this
Tom so so there's uh
Christopher do you want to should I let
you share because
sure I guess I could I could quickly
share I I think you should share
Christopher if you don't mind because
you're fine
um but I'll I'll keep taking notes and
things okay so here's uh let me see this
is it a different notebook but um
right so so uh uh for example tell me
that actually the font a bit bigger so
um
right so so for example you could have
something like uh
a penny Ginger would be fine one but I'm
gonna do a slightly more complicated one
right so find shortest tour of you know
graph of uh I don't know
or maybe I should do uh
um yeah something like this right so
okay so so basically we're gonna have
this is going to have let me let me just
I'm just gonna write type hint in a
million places so we can see what this
is so this will be something like an you
know edge of integers you know this
graph will be a your you know this list
will be a
you know a list
of edges of integers
um this whole graph will be a
probably just a how do you like the
colon colon bracket
um notation is that working out okay
yeah I I've I've I think it works pretty
well like I haven't had any problems
with it certainly but you actually use
it
yeah I always use it yes but okay
um
right so so and then and then find
shortest tour
um let's say this Returns the type it
takes a graph and returns a
tentatively named list Tuple of uh you
know
real and then a
so to make this make sense let me run
this so people can see what it does oh
well it actually doesn't work
um
oh because I'm I'm uh
uh
I'm honestly not totally sure why that
doesn't work well if I give it three to
one it should work right there we go
okay right so so it gives it gives the
length of the path and then it gives the
sequence of of you know sequence of
points right so
the point the point would be something
like and you know there's a lot of
complexity in here like for example the
fact that I said this is a real when it
doesn't it isn't always an evaluated
code and I'm not sure what we want to do
there
um but in any case
um right but an example would be then if
I say you know let's say I say uh tour
equals this and then I say uh
well first of all I said Tour Part three
you know I'm in trouble because you know
from the type system this is a length
two thing maybe I'd say something like
Tor part two comma you know one this
only makes sense or like but maybe I'd
say right this only makes sense if uh
you know
because I said two if I said one then
then you know this would be wrong for
example a common error that I've done is
I'll do something like this where it's
like oh you didn't realize that it gives
the length of the tour on the first
argument right right so catch that
for example
um okay mild time not not run time
well let's check it out at check-in time
whether it's compiled or not yeah yeah
so that's what I mean at checking time
not not running time right but but I
mean the workflow that we're imagining
here is
that we have as we say a batch mode of
linting and a forensic mode of linting
am I making sense
I mean the batch mode is you've got a
big blob of code and you go through and
just generate a report of all the things
that might be wrong that's case number
one and case number two that we're
building out is given that you have you
say this was the wrong result so maybe
this is in the suggestions bar maybe
it's generated when there's a message
generated then you can go and do
forensic linting do we all agree about
this this strategy
yeah I mean you you just mean that that
yes sure
because because we're not doing this by
default all the time
where you know it's too expensive and
and then when you do forensic glinting
then the thing will indicate then the
end point of this the intermediate stage
is putting in type hints
and then the end point of this is some
kind of indicator in marked up code of
whether whether it's likely to be a
problem and perhaps there should be a
way of getting the with mouse servers or
whatever they are
um you know an indication of what the
actual type hint type hinted code has in
it does that make sense
sure yeah yeah
okay so next question my guess my guess
is that you're you're most the time
you're going to only look at you know
right you're gonna you're gonna only
look at the type when it's wrong I know
so the endpoint my question is this the
type hinted code
okay so I'm just trying to understand
the workflow here because it's kind of
critical so we don't waste a bunch of
time doing the wrong thing
so one case says we're annotating the
types for the sake of finding holes
where we think the types mismatch and
it's probably a bug in the code okay
that's case number one case number two
is we're type painting for the sake of
feeding the thing into the compiler
and we're realizing there's a again a
black hole in the type hinting system
where the thing couldn't type hint and
that's the thing it can't compile is
that a fair characterization
yeah although I think that I mean the
obvious problem is going to be if it
says oh I couldn't infer the types of
this the question is is that because
there's a hole in your code or is it a
hole in the type inferencing system
either because there's something that
we're missing and oh we just haven't
done the curation yet you know which is
realistically what it would be like at
least initially or because it's like you
know well this is kind of an impossible
case you know you're saving something to
some you know it's some undecidable case
no right okay fine but but then what
we've discussed Tom can you speak to
this I mean what we've discussed is that
we get type hints the automatic type
enter goes as far as it can and then it
says in the pre-compilation mode it says
oh I couldn't infer the types for this
blob of code can you the user tell me
what these types should be is that
correct Tom
yeah I mean that's um I I got an update
from Noah on the this this this project
I mean the first version is just to mark
up the point in you know where the error
was what the thing was that couldn't
make progress next phase is to say these
were the possible choices for the thing
and in particular in cases where it
doesn't know how to move forward because
there's inconsistent you know multiple
choices it's not not inconsistencies
there's just you know it's a bit more
understanding and and you would get a
chance to mark it up to say hey actually
I meant you know this not so we have
candidate ux for this is that correct
I think we're a long way from candidate
ux for that we've got candidate ux for
returning the marked up blob showing you
where the error is um we're not talking
about an error we're not talking about
an error there's two cases here we need
to distinguish them one case says
forensic markup for the sake of
detecting user errors in top level code
in top level code that's case number one
case number two you are trying to
compile a piece of code yeah that's what
I was talking about okay but that's not
an error I mean that's a different thing
I think of it as an error because it
means the compiler can't proceed okay
fine a block which is a blocky blockage
of something maybe it's a blockage
so yes a bushel
I don't know what that is
oh okay fine but okay but but okay
um
okay
but but let's just let's just
distinguish these two cases right one is
uh you know era infra user era inference
the other is compiler blockage and yeah
the expectation is
in the case of user error
that the person is just going to modify
their code they're going to edit their
code right and because they made a
mistake
okay in the case of compiler blockage
they are going to add a type hint
that's maybe there might be other
remedies they have as well
um you know but yeah
like what they might say I can use a
slightly different function here or
right you know so they rewrite something
so one case but but the the simplest
case is they add a type end the thing
says I don't know what to do here and
you add a type hint and then it knows
what yes yes that's that's that's
correct okay fine and the and the ux
should basically be something which in
you know I think what it should do
roughly is it it should say you know a
bunch of things should turn green or
whatever and because it could do the
types and then other things should turn
some other color and then you go in and
you can have a nice ux to just wrap a
type hint around the piece of code that
didn't you know that had um I don't know
maybe maybe there's some place where a
little Landing Pad where you can type in
the type pin so to speak or something
like that does that sound reasonable
that that sounds reasonable yes there's
a lot of Machinery front-end Machinery
that would need to be built to support
that but yes let's see whether Noah
maybe we can give Noah this fragment of
the school since he isn't here I think
um he's not here I did Ping him today he
is you know aware of this okay
you know this is just
you know Aubry can you please
mark down the spot of the recording and
then Noah can the equivalent of be
virtually here
yes yes I'll mark it down starting at
about like 12 40. whatever whatever and
tell her if he wants to talk to me about
any of this you know I can fill him in
right okay all right okay
okay I think we understand the
objectives now but we've got to be very
very clear the objectives are in the
forensic case that the thing would
basically indicate with some kind of you
know pink overlay or something the areas
where it thinks there's a problem
I think the do we believe that it's just
it's description of what the problem is
will be sentiently understandable to a
user or is it absolutely hopeless
do you mean in the context of trying to
compile it or no no no no no no no user
error I'm talking the two different
cases here no but I mean I mean I I'm
saying okay I think that at least the
way the errors are set up right now
although it might be possible to make
them better I think they would be I
think to the to the just a totally naive
user they're probably not going to be
very comprehensive that might be
remember we're not talking compiler
blockage we're talking user error first
to begin with okay fine I wrote a piece
of code they don't know anything about
the compiler they don't care about the
compiler they've never even heard of the
compiler it they they ran their code the
thing spewed messages we offered them
the alternative you know do a forensic
analysis of your code I see yeah right
then
yeah I mean
a message saying find shortest tour
returns two elements not ten they would
find that useful yes they would but I'm
asking you given
all that you have is a black hole in the
type hinting system right that's all you
actually know probably
am I correct in the user error detection
that's not totally true I mean usually
the type is it knows more than just that
it failed
oh I failed to unify these types or
something like that yeah
okay but hold on hold on hold on what
we're trying to do is write a function
that returns a symbolic expression that
is festooned with type hints okay now if
the thing comes to an end and it cannot
generate a type hint maybe it needs
another symbolic indicator of what went
wrong the kind of type failure object
right but there's a point it won't it's
not going to annotate if it can't
annotate all of them it's not going to
annotate any of them that makes sense
like either it finds a solution to
everything or it's going to say I failed
and you know this is a description of
how I failed but Christopher actually it
does information going forwards up to
the point of failure so there is some
information there but it will have like
type variables in it and stuff like that
won't it well no no no it'll have
complete it'll have total type Solutions
you know it it depends a little bit wait
a minute we need to be clear about this
because because this will blow up the
whole idea if if what you're saying is
Right basically in the in the compiler
blockage case
I was assuming that many type hints will
actually be there
and that there will simply be this black
hole area which is missing type pins
where it basically got stuck because it
doesn't know what the type of this
particular thing is am I right about
that or are you saying that if it
doesn't know what the type of a
particular thing is it cannot annotate
anything with type heads that's not true
which is not true the last thing you
said is not true it does it does know
things about you know it it does depend
a little bit on some some of the details
but the compart the type inference that
tries to work in a forward mode it's a
global infrared inferencer so it's quite
possible to work code that has to go
backwards or whatever fine but but then
the end result here is it has been my
theory that the thing that we need a
function the modular function that we
need is a thing that takes a piece of
code and and annotates it with type
hints and that that thing would be the
thing which then goes down the line and
says you know now we're all experiment
with writing something like that well I
thought you said that like a month ago
but okay fine well no no no what what I
said well fine what okay because the
idea though is just to have it something
like you have this piece of code or
maybe you have you know
this piece of code and it just you know
highlights some part of this I don't
know exactly what
QX question in red and it says you know
here's your problem okay but wait a
second we've got two different types of
problems and we really need to
distinguish I know we're talking about
this we're talking about the first
problem we're talking about not compiler
blockage okay the compiler blockage will
have the same ux which is using the same
type inferencer and it you know has
exactly the same information but what
went wrong
is different because in the in the
compiler blockage case the likely remedy
is add a type hint whereas in the user
error case the likely remedy is edit
your code
I I'm not uh maybe I'm not sure about
that I mean because the the basic point
is that the things that the type
inferencer will be able I mean right the
thing is that the type inferencer will
be able to reason about is exactly the
same as the things that can be compiled
that's currently of course they might be
compiled full of Kernel functions but
but the point is is that it's not like I
mean
right if you have an error in code that
you're trying to compile this is going
to be the same sort of error that you're
going to have if you're writing code
just in the top level no I I okay this
is the probability that the problem is
fundamentally the type instruments are
being dumb versus you being dumb those
you know the prior probabilities are the
same whether you're writing it in
compiled code or a top level code I'm
I'm confused here okay let me see if I
understand okay so there is a long
transient period where we will not have
completed the type curation process yes
point one point two there are places
where it's kind of undecidable what type
it is and where really it's a question
of the user says well I am you know in
my code this is supposed to be a list of
integers oh if it's not you can generate
an exception but to know that it's
supposed to be a list of integers like
like you know you'd have to solve you
know the Riemann hypothesis to know that
this is always a list of integers but
you're prepared to go out on a limb and
say either user think this is always a
list of integers therefore I will add a
type paint to say it's a list of
integers
yes okay so that case seems to me that
the the way forward you know in the case
where it says I've annotated up to this
point and here all I could do is put
this as a Big Blob of Kernel function a
a big a big arbitrary expression thing
which will then infect the whole rest of
what I'm compiling and I won't be able
to compile anything here
but I I don't think so I mean that that
last part I don't think is true I mean
the whole point about having type
annotations is that you don't have to
infect things because you know hey just
took an integer integer-like expression
or something like that it's going to
return another integral like an
expression but it could also be the case
that that that thing that you the user
know is a list of integers that going
outward from that a ton of stuff would
have resolve types
sure like if you mean if I annotated
something that was missing it might be
able to figure out a whole bunch of
stuff yeah sure yes but I mean but but
so the ux would likely be
I mean let's say that I don't know what
it might be it's some kind of number
Theory let's say let's say that you've
got a bunch of number Theory functions
which take integers return integers Etc
et cetera et cetera but they are a big
nest of number Theory functions as
wrapped around a thing called list
and that thing called list is of unknown
type
right now list factorial and I want to
say by the way this list thing that you
don't know about is a you know exactly
exactly
right but but it might encrust that list
factorial might have a big outer you
know thing of seven layers of number
Theory functions sure they all would say
I don't know what to do because they're
all I mean so so that's a different
question it seems to me is could we do
an analysis given that of these are the
kind of uh you know the critical points
where if you could only annotate this
type then you could trickle down and get
all kinds of information
is that plausible
in other words what is the dependence of
you know well you could know like like
you've got your function factorial there
you could know what possible functions
there are for factorial
s
so sorry the you you know what
what function yeah what types you have
for factorial so you could
you you could say hey if you make you
know this could be a fact this could be
a list of integers and you know that I
know that Tom I know that well I'm
asking is a different question
you know you've got something here where
let's say that that list was the result
of I don't know some something about
chemical elements okay so it's not just
lists which is coming from the outside
it's a thing where we could know the
types
and by the way I don't know if you're
planning type annotation for entity
property things but that's another
interesting thing to think about
um but my question is so in other words
it's a pure internal game that that
listing is something purely internal and
in principle if we'd annotated
everything if we curated everything we
would know the types here but my
question is in a situation like that do
we have any chance to be able to say uh
you know this is the pivot point we'll
annotate this type and then everything
else will flow from it right so the two
cases you mean would be something like
this where it's like well the critical
thing is you know what list is the other
case would be something like this where
we don't know the type of Euler Phi we
know all the other ones we don't know
Euler Phi and so the critical thing is
we need to know the type of this right I
think in both of those cases even just
the existing the way the existing type
in printing stuff works I mean it just
those are the two places that'll give
you the error it'll either say I don't
know the type of list or it'll say I
don't know the type all right I can't
find the definition of Euler five it
takes a you know a list Vector machine
in the compiler blockage case the ux
that we expect is it will be something
where there where there'll be stuff
that's in green that has been type
hinted and there'll be stuff that's in
pink or whatever that hasn't been and
where you basically go in you Mouse over
the pink stuff and it gives you a little
thing that says add a type hint here and
then maybe it gives you a hint for the
hints later right although I mean this
is a very much this is kind of a minor
point I'm not sure the extent to which
there'll be things in green because you
know there'll be software well maybe Tom
can comment on this there'll be stuff
where you haven't really reached it
because you know there's well there
might be a subtree it might have a list
of three elements and two of them
Christopher there's a point at which you
have lists equal I mean there's a yes
is being introduced and it's either
coming from an assignment or it's an
argument
from uh you know a function okay
yeah but but I'm sure yeah but that's
the point at which it it would you know
that would be a useful point to say Hey
you know here's the problem
sure
of things turning green is you've got a
list of three elements one of them has
unresolved types the other two are fully
resolved on a both known to be returning
you know integers or something
right so those two could go green
am I right yes so a sub tree could go
green but then there's a part that will
be infected yes I think all these things
are possible it's a global inferencer so
of course if those subtrees have you
know it'll carry around those
Alternatives depending upon the last
unresolved thing all right but anyway
the most important thing for the
blockage case is to annotate is to you
know pink up so to speak the the place
where the thing got stuck exactly right
but also just to be clear I mean this is
the same as the checking evaluated code
case
you mean it's going to Pink it in the
same places
I mean maybe the ux could be different
but like realistically it's going to
have exactly the same information it
might as well pink things up in the same
way
oh that's fine but I mean but the remedy
is different
why I I don't think it is because yes
the remedy and the compiler blockage
case could be purely add a type hint
right but okay so we're talking about
okay there's some probability the
problem is at a type hint and there's
some probability it's you made a mistake
yeah I agree but but so but but I the
point is that those I think those
probabilities are the same in compiled
versus sort of checked evaluated code no
no but but but look
okay I don't understand that there's no
point okay in the case where we are
merely using this for forensic error
detection
nobody cares about the compiler in that
case they're just but the type system
will I mean okay if what you're saying
is basically that if the you know
okay I think I understand
the confusion it's okay so the I think
what you're saying is that in the
checking top level code case if it re
says oh I don't know anything about oil
or Phi it will assume all is good and
will say I don't see any problem there
because I don't know anything about it
as opposed to the compiled case where
obviously it's going to complain because
it needs to actually compile it so it's
you know yeah so right but my point I
don't think that's
I'm not sure that's coherent because you
know the type system really doesn't know
the difference between oh I don't know
about oil or five so I can't comment
about whether it's correct and oh you're
doing the wrong thing here because
oilify doesn't exist or okay look look
the point is
in code that has nothing to do with the
compiler
it seems implausible that people are
going to spray tight pins into it
our system spray tight hints as a way to
get a it's a heuristic way I mean and
those tight pins might flow through code
assistance rules
I I'm not sure what you mean by spread I
mean as an are you talking about
spraying type hints is an implementation
Detail no yes I'm I'm saying I'm saying
my what I'm imagining is that in the
case where we're doing forensic error
detection of user errors right forensic
art detection the things spewed error
messages you say tell me give me some
idea what you think is wrong okay then
what I'm imagining the implementation of
that is is first it goes through and
annotates with type hints then the code
assistance rules look at those type
hints as to give them a leg up on what's
plausible and what's not
and the code assistance rules then
report on things they think are wrong
possibly so even if the type system
fails so even if the type system says oh
this looks wrong it's still up to the
code assisted system whether it wants to
take them to account and trust it
perhaps yes I mean I I don't know we
have to try this it could be that that
it is a you know look it's like like the
the statement if your code looks really
ugly
it's quite possible that it's wrong it
has some weird extra case it's quite
possible that that case is wrong because
that's just the way the language design
works so similarly here it could be the
case and I don't know because we don't
have experience with it that as soon as
there's a type you know inability to
annotate types that that's a place where
there's likely to be another I don't
know if that's a user level heuristic
right I don't think we know and I think
what I'm suggesting is that the expected
workflow is we surface the type hints so
that when we make rules because you know
if you look at the code assistance rules
right now there are a bunch of things
that say you know duplicate case in a
switch something like that okay sure
there are more types of rules that you
can write if you know type if you have
type hints I guess so okay fine uh sure
right and so it's sort of a I mean I
think this is kind of a
I'm not sure exactly what rules the type
hints will help with and what I mean the
point is is that
if we're talking about the case where
the oh the code doesn't compile in other
words the type imprints are can't infer
the whole thing the question is is there
still a useful information in the typing
well okay so yeah
with with Brenton as we've been going
through code assistant stuff he said oh
I can't make a rule for that I would
have to know the types
sure okay so my assertion is that if you
knew the types then you could make a
bunch of rules he's talking what he's
talking about there is things like
flowing think value you know types
through variables so you have module you
know x equals something and then a bit
later you have
you know something where it was all
literally in one place he could tell it
but he could give a useful thing but he
couldn't follow it through the you know
the flow through variables I think it's
not I think it's more than that I think
it's something like I think I mean we
have to look it up but I mean there's
there's many many rules that I proposed
where I've been told we can't do that
yet because we don't have type
inferencing
okay so what I'm imagining is that most
of the rules operate on a contact
concrete syntax tree and basically are
just pattern matching rules that say if
it looks like this then generate then
then make this code assistant suggestion
all I'm suggesting is that it operate on
a contact concrete syntax tree with type
annotations sure right yeah but but it
was things like it was things like you
know you wanted an error but append you
know one comma five to be you know so
that right
but but if you had x equals one and then
append X comma one that would yeah right
right
you see this was the sort of thing
Brenton found hard yes correct okay so
fine so let's talk right I don't know
how important that is but it's very
important look it's the blocking item
for code assistance okay right right now
code assistance is is little more than a
toy
the cases I actually disagree with that
I've gotten I think if you're using it
in a text editor and you have the linter
running all the time and so on it
actually gives you you know quite useful
things nothing else stuff like I mean
there's stuff that you get in that
environment like oh there's an unused
module variable I mean that's an example
of a super common one right no that's
useful or probably missing semicolons
can I say something good yeah there's
other compiler
kind of tools that can help with things
like this there are use def chains
so you can follow the definite you know
the definitions of Like A and B back to
where they're defined
that's also what's quite hard for yeah
that's useful that's definitely useful
but but my point is this
I I think about type you don't need type
inferencing okay all right we need a
pattern for something where we take the
concrete syntax tree which is presumably
the thing on which the code assistance
rules are being applied and we annotate
it using whatever we can annotate from
the early uh passes of the compiler
so you're telling me that there's this
new staff thing is a different
annotation but the whole point is we
just need a framework for doing
annotation from compiler technology in
the contract syntax tea tree and the and
the end result that there should be a
function that basically just says
annotate this concrete syntax T tree
first give it an expression and an
evaluated expression generate the
concrete syntax tree without annotation
second take the concrete syntax tree or
I don't know which which whether it does
both at the same time and produce
annotations based on these parts of the
compiler pieces of compiler technology
does that make sense
I think so yeah yeah okay so in the case
of this append example what would be
what could what would would the type
inference uh be the thing what would it
do and would it complain it doesn't need
type inferencing for this well
needs to know right I mean so here's
here's the thing right I mean
right I mean this makes some sense the
question is what okay we're basically
saying the type inferencer won't be able
to infer everything but it'll be in for
some things and and maybe the code
system stuff can use what it can infer
so basically what we're talking about is
the code assistant thing is going to use
this somewhat unreliable type inferencer
in the sense that if it inferred
something you can maybe trust it but if
it couldn't you don't know anything so
in this case for example if it said oh
well I know various definitions of
append I don't know any definition of
append that takes an integer in its
first argument right right do does the
coda systems code assistance system
trust that
yeah right well that's in the case of a
pen it probably does in the case of
something else I'm not sure it does
right but that's up up to it to generate
that's why it has a layer of rules on
top of this annotation The annotation is
merely just like the concrete syntax
tree is
you know
kind of this is what you're dealing with
and then so well for example no sure
sure I I all I'm saying is that I think
we need to think about like
right the type inferencer will be
unreliable in one way or the other right
and we just need to think about what is
the useful thing to give to the code
assistant stuff so that it can actually
have rules so it's not just like oh I
have this piece of information but you
know if it tells me it can't infer it
that means nothing and if it tells me it
can that also be nothing and so I you
know it's useless so we need to know
what annotations are you know and
whether it needs annotation confidence
or whether it needs a definitive I don't
know okay so that's case number one so
we need to actually figure out what
we're because I think it's the very
important thing that I keep on
emphasizing is rather than this being
somewhere in the innards of the code
assistant system I think we need a
pipeline where we actually return a
symbolic annotated thing which then we
can operate on with rules does that do
people agree about that
you you mean similar to how the code you
know parser returns a contract concrete
syntax tree yes that is that's right yes
I mean so you do I mean I think that
probably is just
I mean I think the concrete syntax tree
has all sorts of generic ways of
annotating it so it's probably just
yeah
object yeah I think that's fine but I'm
just saying it's got to be returnable as
a as a something where for example
people could write wfr functions that
operate on that and experiment with lots
of different ways to do you know
particularly batch linting
are making sense
yeah sure sure
okay all right so now just to make sure
I understand in the case of compiler
blockage
what you guys are confident that you can
basically indicate in sort of pink where
the compiler got stuck where the type
inferencer got stuck and that you click
on the pink and it gives you this thing
that says you can add a hint here here
are potentially some hints for the hints
are we are we I'm not sure that you can
add a hint here is yeah yeah I mean you
can mark up points where it got no no no
I'm I'm saying the user the ux in the
end would be you see a copy of your code
the code has pink points in it
okay which are the places where the type
inferencer got stuck
okay at that pink Point like that list
case we just did above you could add
something that is a wrapper a tight pant
around the list that then would resolve
that pink Point okay but the point is
that it's not it's okay a couple things
the first thing is that this case where
you need to annotate this is I mean this
would never work because it needs this
needs to be defined somewhere right and
normally it'll be wherever it's defined
we'll make it clear what its type is the
case there there are two cases here
there's the case of this thing basically
can't compile the way you've written it
because the types don't work right for
the purposes of the compiler and then
there's the case of oh there were a
couple options and it couldn't really
figure out what was going on because it
you know it couldn't tell what kind of
list you meant or something like that
right
the first K first of all the first case
I think is much more common
like more often it's well it won't be
common in the early stages of curation
because there'll be tons of stuff where
we simply missed it
right but but then
right right there are also some cases
where it's sort of like
I mean I'm not sure these are all going
to live forever but there are some cases
where it's sort of like this is
something where the types you know like
okay if you have uh you know an uh right
right now like if you have an if
statement that has different types in
the true and false branches right I mean
if we have Union types and so on maybe
we can just represent that it's not an
error but but right now it is an error
right but that's not something where
it's a matter of one it's not a matter
of oh well we're just missing that
functionality in the compiler I mean
maybe we should eventually but but you
know what I mean and the other you know
no type hint will save you
um okay but but then then then that's
okay fine then that's a case where we've
got to say this code well it's not a
question okay I mean I think I think I
think telling people look this is just a
matter of like the compilation failed
give a reasonable message about what
happened
whether that message it shouldn't tell
you you know oh write a type hint that
says this okay it wouldn't be an error I
get you a point I get your point but I
okay the most important thing is you've
got a big blob of code and rather than
just saying oh I can't compile the whole
thing goodbye
what what we're looking for is something
where there are small pink points within
that code
where you can scratch your head and say
well can I resolve this pink point I had
thought oh you resolver with type hints
you're saying there are cases where type
hints are not enough there's other
there's other remedies okay and you have
to rewrite the code basically what other
remedies are there other than you
rewrite the code I mean I I think it's
just all the standard remedies of your
code doesn't work no I know but it's not
a question that doesn't work it's the
compiler couldn't compile it and that's
our fault
no short short but the solution I mean I
think the solution is either going to be
oh it's just the type inference or got
confused but fundamentally the
functionality exists to compile this in
which case yes it is a matter of adding
a type hint nope and then and then
there's the case of the functionality
doesn't exist right and so the way
you've written it this just can't work
right in which case you know we have to
rewrite it you have to rewrite it yes
yeah that's fine or or you just have a
Big Blob of code that is uh well let me
ask you this could could one just have
it be the case that this piece of code
will not be compiled this inner piece of
code won't be compiled but on its way
out you're casting the result into
something which is of a particular type
is that a feasible remedy
I think so yeah I mean we talked about
we I I forget I forget if we talked with
you I mean Tom and I have talked a
little bit about having something like
that it's a little bit related to this
if compiled a little bit related to this
if compiled thing but but I mean the
idea
right I mean there's some slightly
complicated stuff about well you have
this evaluated section you know there
are maybe compiled variables that need
to be used in the evaluated section
stuff like that but I think ultimately
that could be doable all right let's
turn to the actual supposed topic of
this meeting which is the the the
curation of types so I think I think we
Now understand what these are going to
be used for so let's take a look at what
the ideas are for the actual curation
process there's actually one more useful
piece of information that we might want
together and that is to know whether
functions that operate on lists can be
paralyzed or not
like things like uh things like side
effects yeah I mean map and uh select
can work independently on on sub pieces
of the input but the fold list on a slit
next list cannot
so this this kind of information would
be useful to have well but so this is
also inside parallelized one can imagine
a a pinking approach that shows what
things inside paralyze won't paralyze
and which will is that right I mean
we've discussed that in ECE that are
supposed to be meeting about that with
with a front-end team I assume okay okay
fine but then
but that's another pattern may be
different from the compiler of just you
know you've got code and it's Rewritten
it inside parallelize and it's at the
user assistance level it is coloring
things
but
okay
okay
there must be other cases like that that
well but you're basically saying in the
concrete syntax Tree in addition to
these whatever you're calling them you
Steph chains there's also side effect
wrappers saying this is side effect free
this is pure code Etc et cetera et
cetera
am I correct so those are additional
annotations that you should be able to
request when the concrete syntax tree is
being generated
does that make sense
yeah I think so yeah customer does that
make sense to you yeah yeah I I sure yes
I think some of that will probably well
yeah yeah
I mean so but we're just concentrating
the sort of symbolic effort into a very
annotated concrete syntax tree
and then we know sort of what the output
is supposed to be all right let's let's
go back to the original topic here yeah
okay Tom do you have more stuff in that
notebook or no no I think I think that
notebooks
yeah
finished but Jose has some interesting
stuff by the way but let's look at do
you seem to have an agenda here so why
don't we look at it well I just have a
few things I mean so so
right so I mean I I did sort of a you
know I spent some time I took a bunch of
you know a list of symbols sorted by
frequency according tool from language
data which honestly was not the best way
to do this but you know I took a bunch
of symbols and I sort of categorized
them based on you know these four things
so basically you know
things that already compile like map
things that are quote unquote currently
uncompilable so that usually meant like
options and stuff like that where it's
sort of like this this is just a piece
of the language that isn't really
supported in the compiler
you know kernel functions this would be
things like mine shortest tour and then
re-implemented
this usually was things that were either
you know things like map indexed where
it's like that's a great you know it's
not that hard and it's also the sort of
thing that that's one of the sorts of
things that really should be compiled or
it's something where it's like super
trivial it's just a you know a compiled
expression declaration you know for
example something like um you know RGB
color for the most part could just you
know it's just trivially compilable
um so you know right I also many things
were flagged with multiple ones like RGB
color had both three and four for
example so right so maybe I first these
are some of the results so I looked at I
don't know however many you know a
couple hundred functions or something
so
right so I mean the biggest again this
is a bit of a weird set because it's
these very common functions so things
like you know lift and plus are kind of
a lot of them but um right but I mean
the point is there are a lot of Kernel
functions there are a good number of
re-implementations but a lot of these
are tagged as both kernel function and
re-implementation because basically you
know the core of it would you know
would probably be you know a kernel
function you know all the the
complicated stuff would be in a kernel
function
um and then most of this is like options
and things actually I think I have a
visualization
uh this is a little bit broken with this
width but yeah I mean so you can see
sort of for some of these different
things how they how they categorized
um
interesting okay but yeah I mean of
these very popular and this is very
rough I mean I spent okay so there's a
lot of second on each other there's a
lot of red so those which would be
successfully in other words this project
of annotating things that become kernel
functions makes sense
I think so yes yes right okay and the
re-implementation
is so
you know doing that
so that again you think those are fairly
straightforward re-implementations
most of them yeah I mean the ones that
are only tagged as re-implementation are
usually simple
um but like dollar failed dollar failed
is it you know trivial re-implementation
and there's so many purely compiled
functions that need to be able to return
a dollar failed so it needs to be kind
of re-implemented like the right way to
do is to re-implement
foreign
listed as unsupported would be um uh
math functions or functions that that
have symbolic math objects you know like
integrate or something but but that
might be you know that might be
resolvable right but this thing about
rapping look let's say you have a
definite integral hopelessly
uncompilable inside
but the result is a number
yeah so with a cost
you could actually have that be a piece
of be part of a compiled code right or
or if you had one of these you know
whatever you want to call it you know uh
uncompiled section I mean that's not the
name but but right so if it might if my
compiled code is uh you know
who plus uncompiled section of integrate
um whatever right I mean this
but isn't that kernel function
Christopher no
well it's very similar to Kernel
function and it might be you know
in terms of uh implementation it might
be basically the same so you can already
write this as kernel function by writing
something like you could certainly write
you know that but you don't want to
but you want to pass arguments into it
sometimes you do sometimes you don't and
also maybe you want to be able to
automatically pass arguments so if I say
typed R comma machine integer
I want to be able to say you know
ARG plus X
right yep but if you're writing that
it's different from kernel function
sure yeah
but I think that this would actually be
quite a useful thing to have fun so it's
like a kernel function which has which
has things possible into it it's like
automatic binding so
all right okay so let's come back to the
actual
um all right
so
I would have thought that it's worth
distinguishing already compiles from not
applicable because I think we could
imagine in documentation putting a
little little flag for when things
compile
yeah although the only the only somewhat
difficult thing with that is
um
there are a lot of things well
there are a lot of things that at least
should only partially compile where it's
like well we compile the main use of two
usages but we don't do all the options
right all right so can we start looking
now at what in the case where one is
trying to annotate so re-implementation
it's just going to be something that is
part of the compiler essentially part of
the runtime library in effect
right I mean it's just some core thing
yep
okay so let's look at the ones that are
kernel function
um I think I have a way of uh oh maybe I
lost it I had a way of organizing it
there we go
right so now it's it's by category
there are some of these though that I
just noticed that looked
I'm not sure if this if I generate this
the right way because there's some like
I saw you know plot ranged I saw
re-implementation but it shouldn't be or
like plot time that's an option but but
okay yeah in any case I do think there's
some general thing that should be done
for options but that's a different story
okay let's look at the ones where I I
agree the most important stuff that is
you know the stuff that is like you know
random list manipulationy functional
programming code that's the stuff that
seems to me the most important to you
know to put in this kernel function
wrapper or do the re-implementation
things so that we can just make any of
that type of code compile because that's
the stuff right that one's gonna it's
gonna have the highest leverage that's
the place where yes so and most of that
does compile the cases that don't are
almost all associations okay but but it
needs to compile in the wild okay well I
don't know what's happening with that
but in the wild I've never been able to
get things to compile
I mean I've never actually had an
example where a piece of in the wild you
know not particularly fancily written
list manipulation code actually compiles
right but usually it's because there's
an association in it like I've I've I
I've had a similar experience I have had
a few things that have just in the wild
compiled but they're all you know
they're almost always things that were
purely dealing with lists no so what is
the story of implementing associations
well okay go ahead basic
I mean Tom can probably say more about
this than me I I believe that we should
basically just make a version of you
know make an association type
realistically two Association types
Association vector and Tuple in the same
way that we have list vector and list
Tuple and we should just do it using
basically the hash table uh hash table
type no I think that's I think that's a
bad idea I think we're better to wrap
the association expression
immutable you'd quickly run into
terrible consequences so well okay so
here here's sort of the the issue right
so for lists right now we have three and
a half
things let's say so we have list vector
and list Tuple let's forget about the
Tuple types okay we have list Vector
which is basically the native compiler
way representing lists you can have
listed anything it doesn't have to be
expression serializable or anything like
that then we have packed arrays which
are kind of the Native kernel way of
representing certain kinds of lists and
arrays and that has various nice
features like the fact you can pass it
to and from the kernel you know for free
there's no conversion that has to happen
yep so
similarly there's value in having
something like the packed array for
associations something that's you know
it's just the kernel Association you can
incorporate it on the compiler but you
can pass it back and forth easily but I
think it's also we should make basically
you know partly because this is easier
and it's a thing that we could probably
do quicker which is basically just make
the list vector
for associations this is purely in the
compiler you know
with the data container project we are
trying to make essentially an inner
something like associations
so that's the thing to plug into when
it's ready it's not ready yet well I
also think
that that's not exactly the problem
though the problem is more has to do
with for example right I mean
associations the way associations work
in the kernel did you know the keys and
values are expressions they're not
integers I know nothing else right so
it's like if you're that means you know
if you're compiling things you either
have to be able to serialize whatever
things are to expressions
you know or your toast no but but I
don't I mean the same way that packed a
raise pack to raise fundamentally there
are only a couple types of Pancakes
I think we should just have a thing look
I think that the 90 case is associations
whose keys are strings
and whose
I mean unfortunately the types aren't
always the same of all the elements but
then the other point is I think the 90
case is that you're not mutating the
association at all it's just you make it
somewhere and then you access pieces of
it
so that means there's no append there's
no replace no nothing like that don't in
that case if if it's not mutating it
then it could be it could be a hash
table Christopher well or it could at
least be immutable I mean I think it
should have the same semantics we just
do the same semantics in the top level
which is if you call a pen it'll make a
new Association if you call associate
two it'll modify but that that'll have a
horribly different Behavior so so don't
listen listen most of the time when
people use associations they are not
mutating the association so I I dispute
that I'm well I think I think yes
although I'm compiled code I can imagine
people doing it more because one of the
reasons they don't do it is because it's
usually you know if you're writing
something it has a loop and it's adding
to the association this is a bad idea
but no no no sorry that's nonsense it's
a very good idea to add to an
association
compiled code I would say like like if
you're if you have a oftentimes it's
more efficient to you know get all your
rules in a row and call merge in the top
level than it is to call a loop that's
inserting a million times into an
association that's because that's
because Loops are slow no exactly but
but that's why people use compiler right
but you're trying to write it that way
right but so so I think the case we
should support first because the first
case is people have existing code and
they want it to compile and that case
should be a mutable associations
and we can clearly detect I I don't
understand what you mean associations
are immutable so how sorry I'm I'm not
non-modifying associations associations
so you can't you can't modify the
association that's correct you right
okay generate it that's fine I think
we'll quickly find that unsustainable
but fine that's that's fine but then you
detect and the compiler whether it needs
to be the other type
but so I I'm just kind of confused
though I mean
isn't this just the same as top level I
mean if you if you try and append to it
it'll copy it and it append to the copy
right crystal how Association Works
Christopher
okay I mean if you call append though
and returns a new Association yeah you
still have the old one and you have the
new one
but it doesn't it it doesn't copy every
element Christopher
how does it work oh so sure
hugely complicated try business that
shares common most of it shared you see
it's a try thing
so you mean when there are two
associations one of them is longer than
the other you're saying if I were to
look at the internal memory usage if I
do this in a loop and I append to an
association that the memory usage yeah
it's going to be a big big hairy tribe
wait wait a second yeah it will not be
quadratic
surely everybody knows this I mean sorry
how could we not know this
well it's brilliant Tom but I didn't
know it okay so you're saying if we
append on a loop
that's yeah
so if I if I do this and I'm gonna
well keep the associations around and
then I'll also give the memory in use
and we'll say uh
brilliant
with a linear line very impressive Tom
but but this is the value proposition of
associations this is why we freakingly
wanted to add them
I don't think people know this I didn't
know this yeah well because we don't
tell people anything well okay fine
there's uh it's all secret there's a
vector there's a like a list book
there's a data structure called the
mutable Vector that's the same sort of
thing but but it's for
um
you know it has uh look up
um you know indexing so you can append
and yeah
this is presumably in login not actually
linear there's a there's a log there's a
log in there correct down yes yes yes
but but log is a log is
right yeah correct
it's very interesting it's very
impressive well done look look at the um
yeah yeah so you could append like like
a pending to it is is fun this this is
like a list but you can append to it
right
it's really wonderful and actually this
is something people should really know
about and I I don't know whether we have
I mean maybe we should have at least
workflow documentation about repeated
appending to lists or something or
repeated you know we we we we should
have that so well what I would like to
do would be to implement Association as
a data structure you see that's that's
what I've got but Tom Tom let's deal
with the first case which doesn't use
this thing that none of us knew was
brilliantly there right okay well it's
just being used as a receptacle of of
index data okay so let's come back to
the question so I gather there were some
other things that Jose had to say about
this curation process or something
related
um well um can I share for a moment yes
definitely oh
so
I have worked in in several projects
related to to types so I'm going to
mention three so the first one is the
predictive interface where we have like
syntactic types and then something I
wanted to mention is that something very
useful for us and I don't in the
predictive interface and I don't know
whether we want it here is that we have
semantic derived types for example
imagine that we have string lists so a
list of strings so we separate a list of
contexts or a list of directories
because if we know anything in a list of
contexts we can then suggest to use it
as a in contact path and things like
that so it's very powerful
this is an idea that we might want to
consider in this project
how how well built out is this stuff for
the predictive interface I mean and also
you know maintaining the predictive
interface is non-trivial and emergency
these things will be really nice
yes yes
um so this project we are talking about
here in this meeting is going to be
something similar because we have to go
through all the functionality and we
need the knowledge from the developers
and and making I mean judgment decisions
on yes how many parameters Etc so here
we have of the order and a few hundred
types
um
right most of them are are syntactic
and then these are the types of data
packlets and yeah and so the list is
something very important let's use one
and so this is where the the structure
goes deeper
and yeah so this is what we have here
very nice
okay this is one project a second
project is captions and here what I did
and you see I have to review it for
every version is to separate this is a
partition of all the 7000 plus symbols
into right now 203 different areas
and so this is I don't know we can take
associations so here there will be all
the association symbols and I did this
in order to simplify the translations
into Spanish so it's easier to translate
a bunch of related symbols because you
can make the same decision on how to
translate
individual so this is a question of
bucketing I mean does well from language
data know about the things that you have
yes
yep
um so this is here so there is some sort
of graph so these are graphs of the
areas and subarias Etc I have a tree
here which shows it better
and so these are the sub areas right so
there are the 203 areas
and so you can do something like this
give me all the date symbols
right are the is the hierarchy
represented in Wolfram language data or
only the leaves
I think
there is no hierarchical structure but
you can ask for the language symbols or
the three symbols or code symbols
a minute ago it looked like the
functionality areas you know when you
ask when you take all the symbols and
you ask for the functionality areas it
always gives you a list of length zero
or one
I said so what's your suggesting
Christopher is that given a leaf like
comparison operator or something or
given given a thing which is a leaf from
comparison operator that it gives you
some way in some way the the
um uh the path back to the root of this
of Jose's tree here
is that right sure something like that
would be nice yeah I mean
I I'm just wondering because I mean I I
was also I mean in terms of my
annotating types as re-implementing or
you know whatever you know I think that
the next phase of that I should do it
for a particular area so it's useful to
get these pretty cool yeah right okay so
okay this is also quite wonderful Jose
yeah and this is updated and and all
symbols all system symbols are in one of
these categories and so the third thing
I wanted to mention is that I had to
start this is box 2017. a similar
project to what we are discussing today
and so the and so I I started
alphabetically so I had the all these
symbols
here as an example so the idea so these
are this is my prob my my own notation
so it would be the one of these is
essentially one of the entries in the
definition box
and so you see here for example that I
have things like frequency ratio so this
this is a real number but I'm actually
giving it semantic meaning so this is
the the thing that that was trying to
imitate what we do in the predict
interface
oh yes and and then yeah yeah this is if
it's a type hint that in addition to the
raw sort of functional compiler type it
is also describing something about the
semantic purpose of that
exactly but I think if you are going to
be for example something that will be
very useful would be to say give me a
hundred random expressions of this type
and we feed one of these types and if
it's a list of contacts because you want
to test one of the context functions
it better be real context not just
random symbols random strings
I also think the code assistance system
could really benefit from having
semantic annotation as well if we know
the somatic annotation why not give it I
mean if we know that that list you know
although I don't think we want to
multiply the inner the internal types to
have you know a DMS list as well as a
just an ordinary list Factor
but is that affect that can be done in
iterations in which we go deeper so
perhaps we start with like the first
initial level here
and so yeah so for example audio split
would take a list of audios and a time
and would return a homogeneous list of
audios
yes out of curiosity what is the um
because I see you have a function type
which you know represents the inputs and
outputs what is the type that's just
quotes function is that like a generic
function type or
or what
I'm not sure but go to that so as I said
this is just the beginning I may have
100 a few hundred symbols out of the
seven functions so I have at the
beginning here
like let's see
so
yes so these are the definitions of
of the things I have been using there so
our duration for example can be a
positive real or a quantity
and uh right the audio types the Audio
models
so nice yeah so this is something that
requires Us in the predictive interface
it requires work from the actual
developers the the developers who can
make the Judgment calls of what is
important what should be nice to
preserve
Etc so the same thing happened in the
predictive interface I wrote several
thousand button rules here for the
simpler things but then at some point I
had to continuously contact the the
developers of various areas
so parts of this also remind me of I I'm
not sure if you're familiar with closure
is this thing called spec which for a
long time I've been meaning to implement
a version of in Mathematica but this
this looks a bit similar to that
actually
I don't know it yeah yeah that's fine
well it seems to me that
maybe Christopher could work with Jose
to basically try and make a sort of
Master template
foreign
types I know I know which is why we want
to make a master template which we can
then deploy for all of these purposes
well what do you mean by Master template
I mean you just mean like syntax like
this for writing apps yeah sharing a
function that it can then be deployed as
this is how the predictive interface is
going to use it this is how the
translation team is going to use it this
is how the compiler annotation system is
going to work and so on
with a single because I mean I think
what Jose is showing here is that
basically the workflow for the person
doing the sanitation is you go to the
usage message and you uh and probably
you do it for a gaggle of functions at a
time just like for the translation thing
and then you go to the usage message and
you start annotating
start giving the annotations
uh
and um perhaps we should take an area
and consider it an example it would be
good to have an area that other
Developers
I would argue graphs I think list
manipulation is two I mean one it's a
lot of it's already supported in two
it's it's one of the most sounds like a
good one yeah
sounds like a good one and then and then
in the end what one would expect is that
this type of material would basically go
into documentation Pages or something or
some parallel system where do you think
we put this in the end
I think so it should be like we use the
syntax information which is in the
interrupt pages
yeah
so this would be another thing like that
why wouldn't it be in documentation
that's what we're saying John that's
what we just said put it in there
yeah okay right fine but I mean and then
then the other question is whether we
would expose a user level version of
this
I mean we already exposed some of it
because we have a type of
the type of lets you I mean this is a
documented function that lets you okay
you give it a piece of code and it tells
you know whether whether one of the
things we should imagine is that this is
a structured piece of documentation that
you can actually see
you know
what
as something in in in kind of
documentation visible style I'm not sure
maybe just yeah yeah well I was just
just gonna ask I mean so for the
predictive interface for example what is
sort of the format that it needs pipes
in I mean is it it just needs to know
for each function like for each head
basically and for each object what the
type is or
so in the predictive interface we
typically use just strings and the idea
with the predictive interface is that
given the previous output the previous
output gets Associated a type and that
determines what are going to be the next
suggestions
that's why it's important that for
example if we know we look at both the
input and the output and if we know that
the list of integers came from data list
then we mark it as a date because that
makes the next suggestions to be
more right and what what if um I mean
what about cases where it kind of fails
or like if you if you chain multiple
functions together and it doesn't know
what to do with it
well
sometimes by by construction we decide
not to assign any type there are things
that appear so frequently like zero one
true that we just don't offer anything
do we don't assign any time right but
but these These are this is a particular
feature of the predictive interface that
for super frequent things we didn't want
to overwhelm the user with always the
same suggestion
sure sure but I just mean like if you
had for example I don't know if you
called what's called generate audio
generate audio and then you give it a
net chain object right I mean I I really
need to accept it you guys can continue
and should continue
um well I think we should think about
another meeting actually would be more
but you guys are on a roll here but I'm
just really late for something else
so I'm going to disappear but I think
you should continue the discussion of
this particular topic just to try and
Define you know so that we can actually
get going on having the master
annotation
structure and then start annotating
something
right and and make sure that it can land
in all these different places
um
anyway I'm going to disappear but but um
this is this is a lot of very nice stuff
and very important stuff
um okay disappearing see you guys soon
bye
I was going to say that for example for
very recent objects that we don't have
yet in the pre in the predictive
interface type system we just don't
offer anything
right but I mean even apart from stuff
we don't support I'm just asking like
you know for example
if if you you know I saw you know you
have various function types where it
says this is the input types and these
would be the expected output types but
what happens if you you know if someone
just has an error in their code and they
write something that's just incoherent
from the the perspective the types in
here
are you talking about this side there or
or the objective interface
I I meant to decide on the right on the
right yeah so these this is very much
underdeveloped it I okay I haven't
thought completely about what to do in
in wrong cases or
for
many scenarios as I said I I basically
just started alphabetically here with
with some family
how this I cannot answer in the
collective interface we have some rules
prepared for cases in which there are
errors and so we try to help you based
on the error that was emitted
I see and so for the predictive
interface it's really not doing any
inferencing it's just saying these are
symbols that appeared in your code
is that right yeah okay yeah it's all
based on the structure of the input and
the output
but it's not actually going to figure
out that oh hey you know it it does it
actually like do inferencing where it
figures out well this returns this type
and then that means that this next
function will return this type and and
so on or does it say you're using a
graph function I'll make a graph
recommendation
yes it it's generally based on typing
the second thing you said it just tries
sometimes to be a bit more intelligent
and says oh you used this input for
example so I'm not going to suggest you
precisely that function or you used a
graph of this type so I'm going to
increase the rank of this other function
which is related things like that I see
okay
foreign
nothing else just to understand what you
know
right I mean if there were some kind of
grand unification of these type things
you know what what are kind of the
inputs and outputs that each of these
different usages
needs
but I think I think we should try to
First decide the level of complexity
that we want to go here to prepare
something that is not very complex as we
were discussing before and then that can
be extended if needed for some area
and then after we have these then we
reconsider whether it's useful in some
of the other projects which are really
working
yeah I think that makes sense
sounds good well I guess do we have
anything else that we should uh
that we should uh go over
Tom did you have anything else that you
want to to talk about
Tom
well we lost them okay
right well um yeah sounds good then uh
yeah
okay let's stop here and yes you you and
I can commit Christopher and we
developed digital sure yeah and it would
be interesting if nothing else all right
to see that
the thing you had just annotating the
audio example I mean even if it's not
even if it's not real so to speak like
it's it's uh right I mean because again
I I try to do something similar with
graphs using the compiler type system
and it was definitely like I mean part
of the problem is just the compiler type
system is is a bit more restrictive than
that especially with like unions and
stuff like you know Union types and so
it kind of makes a lot of those things a
bit more complicated
um but uh yeah I think it's it's very
it's very useful just to do concrete
areas
um
yeah
sounds good good all right well
bye everyone